Can you pursue a fulfilling career whilst living with bipolar disorder? Coming up today, Laura shares her inspiring journey navigating her diagnosis, the challenges of working in mental health and the resilience it takes to thrive. Whether you are a professional, a student or seeking understanding, this conversation is a beacon of hope and insight. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now we have previously spoken about bipolar disorder on the podcast. If you would like some more information about what it is and the common signs and symptoms,
带着双相情感障碍，还能追求一份充实且有成就感的职业吗？今天的节目中，劳拉将分享她应对确诊的心路历程、在心理健康领域工作的挑战，以及蓬勃发展所需要的韧性。无论您是一位职场人士、学生，还是正在寻求理解的人，这段对话都将成为一盏充满希望与洞察的明灯。嗨，欢迎收听《有志心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我们在之前的播客中也探讨过双相情感障碍。如果你想了解更多关于它是什么以及常见体征和症状的信息，
please do consider checking out the episode I did with Sam Swazinski. If you prefer to listen to your podcasts as an MP3, you can listen to that episode as number 135 of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Alternatively if you are watching on YouTube the episode is called What is Bipolar Disorder? Trauma symptoms and manic episodes that was part of our special trauma series. If you do find this content helpful please do like, please do let me know in the comments why you are watching, what stage of your career are you at, are you looking to gain some more information for yourself, for the service you work with or for people that you care about. With no further ado, let's dive into this episode and to speak with our guest for today, Laura.
请考虑收听我与萨姆·斯瓦津斯基（Sam Swazinski）合作的那期节目。如果你更喜欢将播客作为MP3收听，你可以收听《有志心理学家》播客的第135期节目。或者，如果你在YouTube上观看，这期节目的标题是《什么是双相情感障碍？创伤症状与躁狂发作》，这是我们特别创伤系列节目的一部分。如果你觉得这些内容对你有帮助，请点赞，请在评论区告诉我你为什么在观看，你目前处于职业生涯的什么阶段，你是想为自己、为你所工作的服务机构，还是为你关心的人获取更多信息。话不多说，让我们深入今天的节目，与今天的嘉宾劳拉进行交流。
Hi, just want to welcome along our guest for today, Laura Templeman. Hi, Laura. Hi. Thank you so much for being here. And thank you also for pitching this episode to me. Oh, well, thank you for having me. Thank you for saying that you'd be delighted to come on and talk about this,
嗨，欢迎我们今天的嘉宾劳拉·坦普尔曼（Laura Templeman）。嗨，劳拉。嗨。非常感谢你能来到这里。也谢谢你向我推荐这期节目。哦，不，谢谢你邀请我。谢谢你说你非常高兴能来谈论这个话题，
because I know talking about mental health and personal diagnosis can feel difficult at times. Yeah, it can, but I like to use it as a means of trying to inspire other people and especially having my own mental health diagnoses and working in mental health. Obviously it can cross paths with kind of personal experiences and things like that. So, yeah. Oh, well thank you. So the aim of today really is for us to think about whether it's possible to work with a bipolar disorder diagnosis and it might be that someone's listening to this or watching this trying to pursue
因为我知道谈论心理健康和个人确诊有时会让人觉得很困难。是的，确实会，但我喜欢把它当作一种试图激励别人的方式，尤其是当我既有自己的心理健康确诊，又在心理健康领域工作时。显然，这有时会与个人经历等产生交织。所以，是的。哦，好吧，谢谢。所以今天我们的目的实际上是思考带着双相情感障碍的确诊工作是否可行，也许收听或观看这个节目的人正试图追求
their own career in psychology or mental health or it might be that they've stumbled across this because they've got this diagnosis or they're considering going down an assessment route that might lead got this diagnosis or they're considering going down an assessment route that might lead to this diagnosis and they're concerned that they may not be able to work in kind of any industry. So that's kind of where we're heading but could you tell us a little bit first about about how you found yourself heading towards a bipolar diagnosis? heading towards a bipolar diagnosis? So I started to notice symptoms quite young, probably when I was around 14 and it was more so kind of like quite severe depressive episodes. Nothing ever really
他们在心理学或心理健康领域的职业生涯，或者他们偶然看到这个节目是因为他们有这个确诊，或者他们正在考虑走上一条可能导致这个确诊的评估路线，而他们担心自己可能无法从事任何行业的 Så 那种感觉。所以这大致是我们今天要探讨的方向，但你能先跟我们讲讲你是怎么发现自己走向双相情感障碍确诊的吗？所以我很小的时候就开始注意到症状了，大概在我14岁左右，当时更多的是相当严重的抑郁发作。没有什么真正的
came of it until I was around 18, 19 years old and I started having access to alcohol, kind of substances and then I moved away from home to go to university and I started engaging in kind of quite unhelpful behaviours, started drinking, smoking, became quite hypersexual and made use of Tinder in more ways than I should have done and that's kind of when the immediate red flag started coming on for me So I tried to chase it up with kind of the southern secondary care services down where I lived in Winchester at the time it didn't really go any further Because I explained that excessive spending I spent about about
结果，直到我18、19岁左右，我开始接触酒精和各种物质，然后我离开家去上大学，开始参与一些相当无益的行为，开始喝酒、抽烟，变得相当具有高性欲，并且比我应该做的那样更多地使用Tinder，这对我来说就是直接的危险信号开始出现的时候。所以我试图通过我当时居住的温彻斯特的南部二级医疗服务机构来跟进这件事，但并没有真正取得进一步进展，因为我解释说过度消费——我大约在四天内花了大约
£2,000 in about four days kind of racked up some debt, things like that. So I left it a bit until I was about, trying to think now, it was 2022 when I was diagnosed, so I'd been 23 and some of those symptoms started coming back and again it was more so the depressive episodes, extreme light dissociation and it was at that point I knew that something was not necessarily wrong but different and I thought maybe I should kind of seek that diagnosis for myself. So I actually paid privately and decided to get a private psychiatrist and get a diagnosis through there. And then I started working with secondary care services for medication who then validated
2000英镑，积累了一些债务之类的事情。所以我把它搁置了一段时间，直到我大概——让我想想，那是2022年我被确诊的时候，当时我23岁，其中一些症状开始复发，再次，更多的是抑郁发作、极度轻微的解离，也就是在那个时候，我知道有些事情不一定是错的，但就是不同了，我想也许我应该为自己寻求那个确诊。所以我实际上自费去了私立，决定找一个私立精神科医生并通过那里获得确诊。然后我开始与二级医疗服务机构合作进行药物治疗，他们随后证实了
my bipolar diagnosis. So it's been a few years coming and it got to a point where I thought I think I need to take it into my own hands to kind of try and figure out what's going on. Oh, thank you. That was a really useful kind of potted history and I hope it didn't feel too tricky kind of doing it in such a quick way. So, it's been a couple of years now. We're recording this in January 2025, so it's been a few years since your diagnosis. Could you tell us whether you were having any thoughts about oh you know what is this gonna mean for my career?
我的双相情感障碍确诊。所以这一切经历了几年时间，直到我到了一个觉得我需要亲自动手去弄清楚到底发生了什么的阶段。哦，谢谢你。这是一段非常有用的小结历史，我希望以如此快捷的方式完成它不会让你觉得太难。所以，到现在已经过去几年了。我们在2025年1月录制这期节目，所以距离你确诊已经过去几年了。你能告诉我们，你当时是否有过任何诸如“天哪，这对我的人生意味着什么”的想法吗？
Definitely so I've always wanted to work in mental health and I think at first I tried to put myself off it I thought you know I've had a long long history of anxiety and depression again kind of bipolar, I've got like a PTSD diagnosis so there's been quite a lot that's been going on and at first I was like surely this is gonna be a triggering career path, maybe I'm not the right kind of person, what if it causes episodes or something like that so I definitely doubted myself when it came to that and because it all happened quite quickly I was diagnosed a
当然。所以我一直想在心理健康领域工作，我想一开始我试图打消这个念头。我想，你知道，我有很长很长的焦虑和抑郁病史，再次，有点像双相情感障碍，我有PTSD确诊，所以发生了很多事情。一开始我想，这肯定会是一个触发焦虑的职业道路，也许我不是那种合适的人，如果它引发发作或其他什么怎么办？所以当涉及到这一点时，我确实对自己产生了怀疑。而且因为这一切发生得相当快，我是在
month before starting my job in the service that I currently work for so I did try to push myself but yeah definitely definitely moments of doubt and sometimes I still get them now definitely not clear of that sometimes there still is doubts of whether you know know, is it going to work? Am I good enough? Things like that. Definitely. Yeah, and I think maybe that's not necessarily exclusive to having a bipolar diagnosis, you know. I've been qualified since 2011 and still am like, you know, am I enough? Are people more exciting and
开始在我目前工作的机构上班前一个月被确诊的，所以我确实试图鞭策自己，但是，是的，肯定有怀疑的时刻，有时我现在仍然会有。绝对没有摆脱那种阴影，有时仍然会怀疑，你知道，这行得通吗？我够优秀吗？诸如此类的事情。当然。是的，我想这可能不一定只有双相情感障碍确诊的人才会有，你知道。自从2011年取得资质以来，我依然会想，你知道的，我够好吗？人们是不是比我更兴奋、
energetic than me? You know? Imposter syndrome can be awful. Absolutely, absolutely. And so it's yeah, I guess it's beginning to separate when that is specifically linked to a mental health diagnosis, and whether it might just be that we're a bit of a low ebb and you know taking things you know got a little bit less resilience in our window of tolerance possibly. Definitely yeah and I noticed that kind of things like burnout especially in a PWP role is definitely well renowned anyway and I feel like my tolerance for that's quite
更有活力？你知道吗？冒名顶替综合征太可怕了。绝对是的，绝对是的。所以，是的，我想这是开始区分什么时候这专门与心理健康诊断有关，以及这是否可能只是因为我们处于低谷，你知道，我们的心理承受能力或者说耐受窗口可能变小了。当然，是的。我注意到诸如职业倦怠之类的情况，尤其是在PWP（心理 wellbeing 从业者）角色中，无论如何都是出了名的，我觉得我对这种倦怠的耐受力在某种意义上也很
low in some sense as well. So I've noticed especially since qualifying and again in the training year it's very intense. I found that I reached a period of burnout there and it seemed to be more frequent compared to my peers who I was doing the course with, had to take kind of quite extended periods of sickness from work. So it was definitely throughout the training year that kind of I think the symptoms became a bit more apparent. Yeah, and like you say, I did a recent podcast episode about what is a PWP. So if anyone's like, PWP? What does that mean? Psychological Well-being Practitioner and there's a recent episode on that that takes you
低。所以我注意到，特别是自从获得资质以来——同样是在培训那一年，压力非常大。我发现在那里我达到了一个职业倦怠期，与和我一起上课的同龄人相比，这种情况似乎更频繁，我不得不请相当长时间的病假。所以在整个培训年里，这些症状变得更加明显。是的，正如你所说，我最近做了一期关于什么是PWP的播客节目。所以如果有人在想：PWP？那是什么意思？心理福祉从业者（Psychological Well-being Practitioner），最近有一集节目带你
through what that is but yeah, they really do put a lot on your plate in terms of client load and in terms of client hours. They certainly do, very high case load, very quick turnover as soon as you're done with one client you get another booked in, kind of supervision, CPD, very very high-pressure job. Yes indeed but a very important job. Absolutely. Like you've kind of painted a picture is that people that that have bipolar presentations or bipolar diagnosis do often tend to have kind of a complex trauma background, but not always, not exclusively, but in the most part that certainly... well I tend to work
了解那是什么。但是，是的，他们在客户负担和客户工作时间方面确实给你压上了很多担子。他们确实如此，极高的病案量，非常快的更替率——一旦你应付完一个客户，就会安排下一个，还有督导、CPD（持续专业发展），压力非常非常大的工作。确实如此，但也是一项非常重要的工作。绝对的。就像你所描绘的那样，患有双相情感障碍表现或确诊的人通常确实倾向于拥有复杂的创伤背景，但并非总是如此，并非全部，但在大多数情况下确实……好吧，我倾向于与
with people with complex trauma so that's how I experience lots of bipolar diagnoses. Could you tell us about your experiences of being medicated, so being under treatment for bipolar, but also then I guess noticing any fluctuations in mood states. So typically we'd have what people would call kind of an elevated mood state or a mania or manic presentation followed by kind of periods of lowered quite significantly low mood. Sometimes it's kind of quite rapid, other times it's not. But how do you manage working with trying to kind of
患有复杂创伤的人合作，这就是我接触到大量双相情感障碍确诊的方式。你能跟我们谈谈你服药的经历，也就是接受双相情感障碍治疗的经历，然后还有注意到情绪状态波动的经历吗？所以通常情况下，人们会经历所谓的崇高情绪状态，或者躁狂或躁狂表现，随后是相当显著的低落情绪期。有时这种转换相当迅速，有时则不然。但你是如何应对并试图去
track all of that? It can be quite difficult at times but I will say like my supervisors and my manager have been nothing short of absolutely excellent with it and I've always been open and honest with them so it can be quite difficult because for me I struggle to sometimes differentiate between what are the signs and symptoms of a actual depressive episode or is it just kind of typical burnout feeling quite tired and more often than not I've kind of noticed the symptoms a little bit too late which has kind of gone into a full depressive episode and I've noticed kind of the elevated mood side I'll take on too much and I still haven't quite
追踪所有这些变化的呢？有时这会非常困难，但我必须说，我的督导和经理对这件事简直好得不能再好了，我一直对他们保持坦诚和诚实。所以这可能相当困难，因为对我来说，我有有时很难区分什么是真正的抑郁发作的迹象和症状，或者这只是一种典型的职业倦怠感、感到非常疲惫，而且往往我注意到症状的时候已经有点太晚了，这已经演变成了一次完整的抑郁发作。而且我注意到情绪高涨的一面时，我会承担太多事情，我仍然没有完全
learned how to manage that so I'll book more contacts in a day than maybe I should I'll take on extra clients, extra calls, I'd work past my working hours doing notes and have absolutely no problem with it. I notice even sometimes in sessions I feel a bit more elevated and more chatty, but it's definitely kind of the depressive and low mood symptoms that I've noticed more whilst doing the job. I have had experience of having quite a severe depressive episode about a year and a half ago, where I had to take about a month off work, kind of extreme dissociation, no appetite, kind of what my therapist at the time described as depressive insomnia. So I'd spend days and days
学会如何管理这一点，所以我一天之内预约的联系客户数量可能会比我应该做的要多，我会承担额外的客户、额外的电话，我会加班完成病历记录，并且觉得完全没有问题。我注意到甚至有时在咨询过程中，我感觉自己更兴奋、更健谈，但我在做这项工作时注意到最多的还是抑郁和情绪低落的症状。我大约在大一年半前经历过一次相当严重的抑郁发作，当时我不得不请了一个月的假，那种极度的解离、没有食欲，就像我当时的治疗师所描述的“抑郁性失眠”。所以我会在楼下醒着
awake downstairs, kind of again a bit of like the substance use. So I started smoking again, drinking a bottle of wine a night and it went really really to a very low point, kind of again kind of some of those negative thoughts. It went, kind of slipped into like the suicidal ideation side of things, so it did get really bad and I think that was me pushing myself to a point beyond burnout as well with the role. So there's been the occasional very severe depressive episode where I have had to take absences from work, um kind of on a day-to-day basis. I do try and push through it which isn't always helpful. Sometimes I kind of ignore my own warning signs and I think sometimes I gaslight myself and be like I'm fine, it's nothing serious, you know I can manage manage it but I think since experience the depressive
度过整整好几天，同样有点伴随着物质使用。所以我开始重新抽烟，每晚喝一瓶葡萄酒，情况真的、真的很糟糕，跌入了一个非常低的低谷，再次伴随着一些负面想法。它滑向了类似自杀意念的方面，所以情况确实变得非常糟糕，我想那也是我把这份工作的压力推向了超越职业倦怠极限的地步。所以曾有过偶尔非常严重的抑郁发作，我不得不请假离开工作；而在日常生活中，我确实会试着硬挺过去，但这并不总是有帮助。有时我会忽视自己的警告信号，我想有时我会对自己的心理进行“煤气灯操纵”（Gaslight），对自己说：我很好，这没什么大不了的，你知道的，我能应付。但我认为自从经历过抑郁
episodes I do try and be more cautious and if I do need to take time off work then I will but I definitely utilize my supervision as well. I'll tell my line manager if I'm feeling a bit, you know, a bit crappy. Sometimes the passion for the job will lower, you know, I absolutely love working as a PWP but sometimes it's just that feeling where I'm like I don't want to get out of bed I'm dreading going to work I don't want to do this what's the point kind of that that negative cycle of those very unhelpful thoughts but yeah my manager and my supervisor have been the absolute crutch to helping me get through that definitely.
发作之后，我确实试图变得更加谨慎，如果我真的需要请假，我就会请，但我绝对也会充分利用我的督导。如果我感觉有点……你知道的，有点糟糕，我会告诉我的直线经理。有时对工作的热情会减弱，你知道，我非常喜欢做PWP，但有时就是会有那种感觉，让我觉得我不想起床，我害怕去上班，我不想做这个，这有什么意义呢——那种非常无益的想法的负面循环。但是，是的，我的经理和督导绝对是帮我度过难关的顶梁柱。
Thank you. And of course, you know, we've got a duty of care to look after you because you're an important part of the staff team, but there's also that duty of care to care for the patients and make sure that they're receiving. And so it's kind of a tricky one to balance, isn't it? And, you know, you mentioned that sometimes you might feel like you're more elevated in sessions, more chatty. And I guess it's just being able to stay on top of that to make sure that you know that this isn't about you. This isn't about us as clinicians. This is about, you know, the care and treatment of the people you're working with.
谢谢。当然，我们有照料你的职责，因为你是员工团队中重要的一部分，但同时也有照顾患者并确保他们得到良好护理的照料职责。所以这是一个很难平衡的问题，不是吗？而且，你知道，你提到有时你可能会觉得在咨询中情绪更高涨、更健谈。我想这只是需要能够掌控这一点，以确保你知道这与你无关。这与我们作为临床医生无关，这关乎你所合作的人的护理和治疗。
Yeah, absolutely. And I think that's the one thing I am is very honest and I've used it in line management again I'll be honest and say look. I'm Really really struggling. I might need to take some time off work There was a time Previously where I got quite upset in a meeting and started crying and I said to my line manager I said the thought of having to sit down with like a client today brings me dread and I said that's not normal I said I'm usually very happy Love my clients love my sessions love the job and I thought I know that this is not normal for me
是的，绝对的。我认为我唯一具备的品质就是非常诚实，我曾在直线经理面前再次表现得很诚实，我会直截了当我说：看，我真的、真的很挣扎。我可能需要请假。以前曾有过一次，我在一个会议上难过得哭了起来，我对我的直线经理说，今天一想到要和一个客户坐在一起，我就感到恐惧，我说这不正常，我说我通常很高兴，热爱我的客户，热爱我的咨询，热爱这份工作，我想我知道这对我来说不正常。
And again, I've always been honest about it and just say like I can't do this right now I am finding it really difficult. Like I said kind of the feelings of dread and things like that so yeah I'm definitely honest because again the clients are what matter within their treatment it's their sessions I'm their practitioner they deserve the best standard of care and my 100% and when it got to a point where I knew I couldn't give that was when I kind of said I think I need to take some time off. Yeah absolutely that's so important I hope it was okay for me to ask you that. Absolutely. Just thinking back to
而且，再次强调，我对此一直很坦诚，只是说我现在做不到这一点，我真的觉得很困难。就像我说的，那种恐惧感之类的情绪，所以，是的，我绝对是诚实的，因为再次强调，客户在他们的治疗中才是最重要的，这是他们的咨询，我是他们的从业者，他们理应得到最高标准的护理，而我百分之百地付出。当事情发展到我知道我无法给予这种标准的时刻，就是我开口说我需要请假的时候。是的，绝对的，这太重要了。我问你这些没关系吧。绝对的。回想一下
what you said about kind of changes in your kind of alcohol use and kind of your mood states and how many clients you're taking on and what times you're finishing. Sometimes it can be really helpful, it might be something you've done already, but to kind of literally have quite a thorough checklist that you complete kind of every day and almost just being doing with numbers in it
你刚才所说的关于酒精使用的变化、你的情绪状态、你接纳了多少客户以及你什么时候下班，有时这真的很有帮助——这可能是你已经做过的事情——但实际上有一个非常彻底的检查清单，你每天都要完成它，几乎就是把数字填进去，
and columns or colors depending on whatever you wanna apply. But in that way, you can kind of quite quickly over a space of kind of a week or a month see those changes especially if you colour code them. Is that something that you've ever tried or considered? You know I know that's something that I've never thought of. I know there's kind of like the regular mood diaries where you write how you're feeling obviously routine and sleep is very important for someone with a bipolar diagnosis. And because obviously too little sleep can actually cause like, you know, manic and hyper manic episodes. And, but no,
并加上列或颜色，具体取决于你想应用什么。但通过这种方式，你可以在一周或一个月的时间里相当快地看到这些变化，特别是如果你使用颜色编码的话。这是你尝试过或考虑过的事情吗？你知道，我知道这是我从未想过的事情。我知道有那种常规的情绪日记，你在上面写下你的感受，显然规律和睡眠对双相情感障碍患者非常重要。而且显然睡眠太少实际上会导致，你知道，躁狂和轻躁狂发作。但是，没有，
that's actually not something I've tried. That sounds like a good idea. Yeah. Almost if you were to draw up a page of, I know you could do it. Like you could do grids of 365 days on a big piece of A3 paper or something, or do it a month at a time. But, you know, almost if you're recording, I don't know, like you could give things numbers and each number has a color. So if you leave work bang on time, then that would be one color. If you have zero alcohol, that would be that same colour. You know all of that so that as soon as things start to to get a bit spicier you're almost noticing those changes.
这实际上不是我尝试过的事情。这听起来是个好主意。是的。几乎就像如果你要画一页纸——我知道你可以做到。就像你可以在一张大的A3纸或类似的东西上做365天的网格，或者一个月一个月地做。但是，你知道，几乎就像如果你在记录，我不知道，你可以给事情编号，每个数字都有一个颜色。如果你准时下班，那将是一种颜色。如果你酒精摄入量为零，那将是同一种颜色。你知道所有这些，这样一旦事情开始变得有点复杂，你几乎就能注意到这些变化。
Does that make sense? That's such a good idea but I know as of December 2023 because I still had a tendency that although I wouldn't drink as often if I did go out and drink I'd get absolutely mashed like almost blackouts or I went to I said the final time I'm drinking is the work Christmas party and I haven't drank in like what about 13 months and I went completely teetotal I haven't touched a cigarette haven't touched a drink and I said I think that's the only way that I'm going to be able to kind of manage that. So yeah, I went completely teetotal from that. Okay, so sounds like you've made some significant changes because you wanted to look at your
这有道理吗？这真是一个好主意，但我知道，从2023年12月开始，因为我仍然有一种倾向，虽然我不会经常喝酒，但如果我出去喝酒，我会喝得烂醉如泥，几乎到断片的地步，或者我去过——我说我最后一次喝酒是在公司的圣诞派对上，我已经大约13个月没喝酒了，我彻底戒酒了，没有碰过一根烟，也没有碰过一杯酒，我说我想这是我能够管理好这件事情的唯一方法。所以，是的，我从那以后彻底戒酒了。好吧，听起来你做了一些重大的改变，因为你想审视你的
coping strategies really. Yeah, and I noticed that again again kind of working in mental health as well about alcohol substance use you know it has very adverse effects kind of that high when you're drunk but kind of the after effects the depressive symptoms and then it was about the effect of more so home life kind of what is it doing to my partner it's not a behavior I want to exhibit around the children you know like mommy used to exhibit around the children, you know like, Mummy used to drink all the time, I really, really do not want that and I thought
应对策略。是的，我注意到，再次强调，在心理健康领域工作，关于酒精和物质使用，你知道，它会产生非常不利的影响，当你喝醉时会有那种高潮感，但随之而来的是后续效果——抑郁症状，然后是它对家庭生活的影响——这对我的伴侣有什么影响？这不是我想在孩子面前表现出来的行为，你知道的，就像“妈妈以前总是在孩子面前……”之类的，你知道，就像“妈妈以前总是喝酒”，我真的、真的不希望那样，我想
the only way that I can manage it is, because I always struggled to manage my usage, I couldn't be one of these people who was just, I'll just have one drink and go home, no that never happened to me so I thought the only way that I can manage this is by getting rid of it completely and I found it easier than I thought I would I thought you know it's gonna get to when I'm feeling a bit down and I'm gonna want to drink but I can't say I've missed it can't say I've missed it at all. Yeah I mean for very different reasons I've sort of stopped drinking probably almost a year ago I've had maybe
我能管理它的唯一方法是——因为我一直很难控制我的使用量，我做不到那种只是“我只喝一杯就回家”的人，不，这从没发生在我身上。所以我认为我能控制它的唯一方法就是彻底摆脱它。我发现这比我想象的要容易，我以为你知道，当我觉得有点沮丧时，就会想要喝酒，但我不能说我想念它，真的不能说我有任何想念。是的，我的意思是，由于截然不同的原因，我大概在将近一年前就戒酒了。我可能喝过一、
One or two but like literally like a glass of wine on holiday because we were all inclusive and I thought Try it was horrible. So but I would say I'm largely T-total and I Found it like easier like because yeah, I'm not going out thinking, oh, I'll have to get a taxi home. I'm going out thinking, well, I know exactly how I'm going to get home. I'm going to drive myself home and I'm going to be sober and it's going to be like this. And then the next day I can get up and feel like I want to get up and exercise and I don't feel like I need to kind of rot in bed. I've never been a big drinker
两次，但字面意思也就是在度假时喝了一小杯葡萄酒，因为我们住的是全包酒店，我想尝试一下，结果难喝极了。所以，但可以说我基本完全戒酒了，我发现这更容易，因为是的，我不会出门还在想：哦，我得叫辆出租车回家。我出门时想的是：我完全知道我该怎么回家。我要自己开车回家，我会保持清醒，一切都会是这样的。然后第二天我可以起床，感觉自己想起床去锻炼，而不需要躺在床上“腐烂”。自从有了孩子后，我从来就不是个大酒鬼，
since having children anyway, but it just gives me my vibrancy. I used to get reasonable amount of colds as well. I would say since stopping drinking, I've maybe had one cold, which is very, very unusual for me, even as an intermittent drinker. Gosh, yeah, I didn't even put two and two together with that. But yeah, like you said, like hangovers were never nice. And for me, it would knock me out for days and going to work, feeling a bit funny, a bit kind of, you know, not as good as really I should have been going to work in but yeah again it used to make me feel really really depressed afterwards kind of like the the beer fear I think it's called and then I realized that I can still have fun without having a drink the people I surround myself with have been supportive and respecting and I've always said I don't mind if
但戒酒确实让我找回了活力。我以前也经常感冒。我可以说，自从戒酒以来，我大概只感冒过一次，这对我来说非常非常不寻常，即使作为一个间歇性饮酒者也是如此。天哪，是的，我甚至没有把这两件事联系起来。但是，是的，就像你说的，宿醉从来都不是什么好体验。对整个人来说，宿醉会让我难受好几天，去上班时感觉怪怪的、有点……你知道的，状态没有达到上班时应有的水平。但同样的，它过去总是在事后让我感到非常非常沮丧——我想那叫“啤酒恐惧症”（beer fear）——然后我意识到我不用喝酒也能玩得开心，我身边的人一直都给予支持和尊重，我总是说我不介意你们在我身边喝酒，那不是让我烦恼的事，但我很幸运，我被周围的支持力量所包围。同样，我的伴侣极少喝酒——我们从不在家里喝酒，我们外出时也从不喝酒，所以我也不被酒精所包围。所以我认为我在那个意义上非常幸运，我周围有极少的人喝酒，但我注意到了巨大的变化，我觉得我的健康状况有所改善——我的皮肤、头发，就像你提到的那种活力，我能够
you drink around me like that's not something that bothers me but I'm lucky that I've been surrounded by the support that I have been and again my partner very very rarely drinks like we've never drank in the house we've never drank when we've gone out so I'm not surrounded by it either and so I think I've been very lucky in that sense that kind of I've had minimal kind of surrounding or kind of people around me that do drink but yeah I've noticed a massive change and I feel like my health has got better kind of my skin my hair like what you mentioned kind of a vibrancy and I can
像你所说的那样，我可以出门，和朋友共度时光，回家后不会感到疲惫或筋疲力尽，然后上床睡觉，安稳地睡上一觉，早晨醒来时神清气爽，而且我确实度过了一段美好的时光。所以这绝对是对我来说正确的选择，而且绝对是朝着更好的方向发展。就像我说的，我一点也不想念它。我觉得我没有错过任何东西。所以我非常幸运，因为我知道这对其他人来说没那么容易，但是的，它对我管用。很好。嗯，我很高兴听到这个。在过去，我会说，哦，而且它更便宜。但事实上，前几天我喝了一杯无酒精鸡尾酒，价格是11.50英镑。
like what you said kind of I can out, spend some time with friends, come home, not feel tired or drained and then go to bed, have a restful sleep and wake up in the morning feeling refreshed and I still had a good time. So it was definitely the right choice for me and definitely for the better. And like I said, I haven't missed it at all. I don't feel I've missed out on anything. So I'm very lucky because I know it's not that easy for other people, but yeah, it's worked for me. Good. Well, I'm really pleased to hear that. And in the old days, I'd say, oh, and it's cheaper too. But actually, the other day I had a mocktail and it was £11.50.
所以它真的不一定便宜多少，我想说。天哪，那真是一杯无聊的11.50英镑的饮料！是的，我只能坚持喝可乐加冰，我也挺高兴的。好吧，那就保持便宜吧。但甚至我最近交谈过的一个人在伦敦买了一品脱可乐，花了5.50英镑。天哪！上帝，太荒谬了，不是吗？真见鬼！确实如此。我想那个时代已经一去不复返了——当我在90年代和2000年代初长大时，有时酒吧会推出促销活动，如果你是指定司机，你的饮料是免费的。现在好像再也没有这种情况了。
So it really isn't necessarily that much cheaper I would say. Gosh that's a boring £11.50! Yeah I had to stick to a cork, a cork and ice and I'm happy. Okay so keeping it cheaper. But even someone I was speaking to recently said they bought a pint of Coke in London and it was £5.50. Bloomin' heck! God that's ridiculous isn't it? Bloody hell! It really is. I think gone are the days, so when I was kind of growing up in the 90s and early 2000s sometimes bars would run promotions that if you were the designated driver your drinks would be free. That doesn't seem to be the case anymore.
不过那也是个绝妙的主意，不是吗？哦，是的，他们再也不会做那种事了。不过那也是个绝妙的主意，不是吗？哦，是的，他们再也不会做那种事了。如今没有什么东西是免费的，对吧？所以我们一直在考虑家庭生活和工作生活，你觉得你周围的人会帮你监测你的状态吗？
That'd be such a good idea as well though wouldn't it? Oh yeah they don't do anything like that anymore. That'd be such a good idea as well though wouldn't it? Oh yeah they don't do anything like that anymore. Nothing's for free these days is it? So we're kind of thinking about family life and work life and do people around you help you to kind of monitor your states do you think? of monitor your states do you think? Oh absolutely and especially my partner like he's been amazing and I think he can start to tell if again my sleep gets quite disruptive you know maybe if I've always been quite bad taking my medication which again as a practitioner we warn clients against but there's times when I've been feeling low where I'm just like oh like Ryan I can't be bothered you know and he knows what medication I take when and will come in with it
哦，绝对会，尤其是我的伴侣，他太棒了。我想他开始能看出，如果我的睡眠再次变得很不规律——你知道，也许我一直很不擅长按时服药，尽管作为从业者我们警告客户不要这样做，但有时当我情绪低落时，我只会想：哦，瑞恩，我实在懒得弄。他知道我什么时候该吃什么药，就会走过来，
and say Laura you need to take it but he'll start to notice when I'm starting to feel a bit lower he can tell again disrupted sleep kind of that like lack of interest in wanting to do things, not wanting to socialise, kind of not talking. I think as time's gone on he can pick up on it really really quickly and for that I'm very lucky because sometimes I don't really notice myself. So definitely like my parents don't know much about it and again to no fault of their own it's just something that I try not to kind of bother them with but again work great and I'll openly tell them if I'm noticing any symptoms but um I always remember my line manager saying sometimes we can tell when people are on the verge of burnout
对我说：“劳拉，你需要吃药了。”他开始注意到我情绪开始变低落的时候，他能一眼看出睡眠被打乱、缺乏做事的兴趣、不想社交、不怎么说话。随着时间的推移，他能非常非常快地察觉到这些，对此我感到非常幸运，因为有时我自己真的没有注意到。所以，是的，我的父母对这些了解不多，同样，这并不是他们的错，这只是我尽量不去拿这些事去烦他们的东西。但是工作上的伙伴真的很棒，如果我注意到任何症状，我会公开告诉他们；但我总是记得我的直线经理说过，有时我们能看出人们正处于职业倦怠的边缘，
because like my case load management wasn't as brilliant as it should have been, and I was getting a bit behind on my notes and my admin just because the motivation energy wasn't there, and I've always said to the people around me like, be honest, don't think I'm going to get hurt or offended or upset. Like if you notice something I appreciate it more if you tell me so I can get a bit more of a grip on it before things get too bad. But yeah my partner has been my absolute staple with things like that and yeah he's very good at recognising the signs and yeah keeping me on track. Great and I know certainly from some of the people I've worked with they especially when they're working find that their secondary care mental health
因为我的病案量管理没有达到应有的出色水平，我的病历记录和行政工作开始落后，纯粹是因为缺乏动力和精力。我总是对周围的人说：诚实点，别觉得我会受伤、被冒犯或心烦。如果你注意到了什么，我更感激你告诉我，好在事情变得太糟之前能够更好地掌控它。但是，是的，我的伴侣绝对是我应对这类事情的中流砥柱，是的，他非常擅长识别征兆，是的，让我保持在正轨上。太棒了。我知道，当然从我合作过的一些人那里得知，特别是当他们在工作时，他们发现他们的二级心理健康
providers can be quite flexible in helping them to tweak their medication to kind of to cope with any elevated or lowered mood states. Is that your experience as well? Yes, they've been absolutely fantastic. So I think I go for a medication review, usually twice a year. I started off so I take Sertraline, I take Limochagine and I take Propanolol. So I've got an SSRI, a mood stabiliser and a beta blocker so a bit of everything. So they do monitor it closely saying is it working and I remember saying if you're experiencing quite severe depressive symptoms and we know it's not working like you should not be getting that on
服务提供者可以非常灵活地帮助他们调整药物，以应对任何情绪高涨或低落的状态。这也是你的经验吗？是的，他们绝对太棒了。所以我想我通常一年去进行两次药物复诊。我一开始服用——所以我吃舍曲林（Sertraline）、拉莫三嗪（Lamotrigine）和普萘洛尔（Propanolol）。所以我有SSRI（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）、心境稳定剂和β受体阻滞剂，可以说是应有尽有。所以他们会密切监测，询问它是否有效。我记得我说过，如果你正在经历相当严重的抑郁症状，而我们知道它不起作用——你绝对不应该在服药期间还经历那种情况。所以一开始我服用的剂量我想是从50毫克开始的，然后我经历了一次相当严重的抑郁发作，接着剂量增加到了200毫克，然后我见到的最后一位精神科医生，
your medication so I started off taking I think it started at 50 milligrams and then I experienced kind of quite a severe depressive episode and then raised it 200 and then the last psychiatrist that I saw what was it ordered a blood test and said we can check lamotrigine levels in your blood and the results came back that there was actually quite minimal amounts so then it was raised from 200 to 300 but I think I've been one of the lucky ones where like my combinations worked really really well for me and it's very rarely had to be tweaked more so just the lamotrigine because obviously that's very trial and error because I think you can go up to 700 milligrams with Lamotra gene so again there's quite a large
怎么说呢，要求进行了一次血液检查，并说我们可以检查你血液中的拉莫三嗪水平，结果显示实际上含量非常微少，于是剂量从200毫克增加到了300毫克。但我认为我是幸运儿之一，我的药物组合对我非常有效，极少需要调整，更多时候只是调整拉莫三嗪，因为显然这需要大量的试错，我想拉莫三嗪的剂量最高可以增加到700毫克，所以有效剂量的范围其实相当大。但是的，他们绝对太棒了，他们倾听我的担忧，如果有什么变化，他们会迅速采取行动，让我参与其中，所以，是的，他们真的非常棒，我现在服用的药物对我非常有效。
window of what works but yeah they've been absolutely fantastic they've listened to my concerns if there's been any changes they've actioned it really quickly kept me involved so yeah they've been absolutely fantastic and what I'm on now works really well for me. Great, and like you said, everyone's an individual so everyone's will be different. So if someone's kind of listening or watching this to kind of get an overview, please don't be alarmed if yours does sound different to what we're discussing for Laura. A really common concern is when people are starting medication is whether they will still
太棒了。正如你所说，每个人都是独立的个体，所以每个人的情况都会不同。因此，如果有人在收听或观看这个节目以获得总体概述，请不要惊慌，如果你的情况听起来与我们为劳拉讨论的不同。一个非常普遍的担忧是，当人们开始服药时，他们是否还会
feel like themselves. Could you talk us through that a little bit? Yes, so I've always been open to medication. Again, it's something that I've always been willing to try. I don't remember any initial concerns. I've taken SSRI since I was about 18 years old but I've noticed that I'm more like myself. Again, energetic, bubbly, probably I'd say even happy, optimistic. So I think actually again I've been really really lucky with my medication and it's brought me back to being even half of my normal self which I'm grateful for. I haven't actually experienced any massive side effects apart from when I started the Lamotrigy
觉得是自己。你能跟我们谈谈这个吗？是的，我一直对药物持开放态度。同样，这是我一直愿意尝试的事情。我不记得有什么最初的担忧。我从18岁左右就开始服用SSRI，但我注意到我更像我自己了。同样，充满活力、兴高采烈，我甚至可以说更快乐、更乐观。所以我认为实际上，同样地，我在药物方面真的、真的很幸运，它把我带回了正常状态的甚至一半，对此我非常感激。除了刚开始服用拉莫三嗪时，我经历过感到相当烦躁、相当愤怒、我的容忍度几乎为零之外，我实际上没有经历过任何巨大的副作用，所以那是最大的副作用之一。但除此之外，我真的、真的很幸运，而且我认为我是少数拥有相当直接经历的人之一。但是的，副作用极小。而且，是的，我对服用药物最初没有任何担忧，因为当时我很乐意并愿意尝试任何有帮助的东西。
and I got like quite irritated, quite angry, my tolerance levels were next to nothing so that was one of the biggest side effects but apart from that I've been really really lucky again and I think I'm one of the rarities where I've had quite a straightforward experience with it. But yeah, minimal side effect. And yeah, I had no initial concerns about taking the medication because I was quite open to it and willing to try anything that helps at that point. Great. Thank you so much. So have you got any kind of parting thoughts really for someone that is, yeah, perhaps finding themselves to be in a position
太好了。非常感谢。那么，对于那些可能发现自己处于这样一种境地的人，你有什么临别赠言吗？
of thinking, what about my career? How's that going to combine with bipolar? Have you got any parting words for them? I think definitely don't doubt yourself. Don't draw a line underneath having a successful career in mental health just because of a bipolar diagnosis. It can be hard, it can be tricky to navigate, it can bring up triggers and uncomfortable feelings but it can be managed. I think I definitely recommend being as open as kind of you're comfortable with kind of your workplace. Don't be afraid to ask for help from work or to ask for any kind of you're comfortable with kind of your workplace. Don't be afraid to ask for help from work or to ask for any kind of special considerations regarding
比如思考：我的职业生涯怎么办？这要怎么和双相情感障碍结合？你有什么临别赠言给他们吗？我想绝对不要怀疑自己。不要仅仅因为确诊了双相情感障碍，就在从事心理健康领域的成功职业生涯上画上句号。这可能很艰难，可能很难应对，它可能会触发一些不适的感受和诱因，但这是可以控制的。我想我绝对建议在你的工作场所尽可能保持你感到舒适的开放程度。不要害怕向工作单位寻求帮助，也不要害怕要求任何针对
workload, clinical contacts. Don't be afraid to say that you're not managing as well, it doesn't make you any less of a practitioner. We're all human and we can only manage the best we can but definitely kind of some kind of you have to look within yourself as well kind of how can you manage it and especially outside of work as well. Self-care and you time is so so important especially kind of like the compassion fatigue can be really difficult but you can do it it is manageable it is doable and I'm so grateful that I've had the experiences with the people around me and with the people that I work for. But yeah, it's manageable and
工作量、临床接触的特殊考量。不要害怕说你应付得不太好，这不会让你有损于作为一个从业者的身份。我们都是人，我们只能尽力而为。但绝对地，你也必须审视自己的内心，看看你如何管理它，特别是在工作之外。自我关怀和属于你的时间是如此、如此重要，特别是同情疲劳可能会非常严重，但你能做到，这是可控的，是可行的。我非常感激我周围的人以及我为之工作的人所给予我的经历。但是，是的，这是可控的，
you can do it and a bipolar diagnosis is not the end of the world, the end of your dreams, the end of your career. Yeah, it can be managed. Thank you that's such a wonderful place to leave it and with a really kind of positive uplifting message. Thank you so much for your time I'm wishing you well with what you're doing now but also perhaps whatever comes next for you in future too. No thank you for having me and giving us space to kind of talk about my bipolar diagnosis and my experiences at PWP so thank you PWP. So thank you very much. Oh, thank you again, Laura.
你能做到，双相情感障碍的确诊并不是世界末日，不是你梦想的终结，也不是你职业生涯的终结。是的，它是可以控制的。谢谢你，这是一个绝佳的收尾，传递了一个非常积极、振奋人心的信息。非常感谢你抽出时间，祝你现在所做的一切都顺利，也祝你未来无论面临什么都一切顺利。不，谢谢你邀请我并为我提供空间来谈论我的双相情感障碍确诊以及作为PWP的经历，所以非常感谢。非常感谢。哦，再次谢谢你，劳拉。
Thank you so much for our guest today, Laura. What a wonderful, insightful conversation that is. Please do, if you find this content helpful, like, share, comment, subscribe wherever you are listening or watching from. It really is the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster, totally for free. I would love to know what you make of this episode.
非常感谢我们今天的嘉宾劳拉。这是一次多么精彩、富有洞察力的对话。如果你们觉得这些内容有帮助，请务必在你们收听或观看的任何平台上点赞、分享、评论、订阅。对于任何播客创作者来说，这真的是你能做的最善良的事情，而且完全免费。我很想知道你对这期节目的看法。
Please do come and connect with me on social media where I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Please do also come and join my free Facebook group, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent, and that is the unique and only place where you can get Marianne's weekly video sessions which are called Marianne's Motivation and Mindset and happen on Friday mornings at 9am but you can always watch on replay too. Please do come and grab your free
请务必来社交媒体上与我联系，我在所有平台上都是“玛丽安·特恩特博士”（Dr Marianne Trent）。也请务必加入我的免费Facebook群组，即由玛丽安·特恩特博士创立的“有志心理学家社群”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent），那是你唯一且独一无二可以获得玛丽安每周视频课程的地方，这些课程被称为“玛丽安的动力与心态”（Marianne's Motivation and Mindset），于周五上午9点举行，但你随时可以观看回放。请务必去获取你的免费
psychology success guide which you can get from my website www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk. As I speak, this is a pretty much brand new website so I would love your feedback on that too. If you value the free content that I provide across throughout the whole year, please do consider buying me a cup of herbal tea to say thank you. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step, you're ready for some career development, please do consider joining us in the Aspiring Psychologist membership which you can join from just £30 a month. Please also do check out the books The Aspiring Psychologist Collective, The Clinical Psychologist Collective and if you work with people who are autistic
心理学成功指南，你可以从我的网站 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk 上获取它。在我说话的时候，这是一个几乎全新的网站，所以我非常希望听到你对它的反馈。如果你珍视我全年提供的免费内容，请考虑给我买一杯花草茶以表示感谢。如果时机成熟，你已经准备好迈出下一步，准备好进行一些职业发展，请考虑加入我们的“有志心理学家会员”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），每月仅需30英镑即可加入。也请务必查看书籍《有志心理学家合集》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）、《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），如果你与自闭症患者一起工作的话
or perhaps you are autistic yourself or want to help someone feel understood and represented who might have an autism diagnosis, you might well love diving into an autistic anthology, neuro narratives of mental health professionals. Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. much for being part of my world. without the merry entrance. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者也许你自己就是自闭症患者，或者你想帮助某个可能被诊断为自闭症的人感受到被理解和被代表，你很可能会喜欢深入阅读自闭症选集、心理健康专业人士的神经叙事。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么这就是你的指南。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，没有快乐的入场。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。